Новий ранок на Донбасі. Поки спокійно, обстрілів не чутно.
Цього достатньо, щоб люди у Гранітному почувалися вдячними.
Досі так зване "перемир'я",
проголошене до початку нового шкільного року, нібито тримається.
Дорога до школи цих дітей пролягає від домівки у підконтрольні сепаратистам райони.
На цьому мосту вони мають показати свої посвідчення особи.
Знімальній групі DW не дозволяють знімати, як діти та їхні батьки перетинають міст.
Українські військові провідники нервують:
кажуть, що несподівана присутність журналістів може спровокувати ворога.
З іншого боку ріки на своїх підопічних чекає директорка школи Леся Коссе.
Вона знайомить нас із Дашею та її двома братами.
Відколи їхні батьки померли, ця школярка-випускниця піклується про сім'ю.
Сашко, усе гаразд?
Я вчора вас майже не бачила.
Цього дня все здається нормальним.
Однак спогади про останні потужні обстріли незадовго до літніх канікул усе ще навіюють жах.
Цього навчального року школа в Гранітному має близько 160 учнів віком від 6 до 17 років.
Це лише половина від тієї кількості, що була до війни.
Інші вже давно залишили зону бойових дій.
"Схід і Захід разом".
Бути посередником між дітьми, що живуть по обидва боки лінії розмежування,
для працівників школи дуже важливо.
Ми знову зустрічаємося з Дашею.
Вже три роки вона ходить до школи через передову.
Ми всією сім'єю йшли до школи.
Раптом почали дуже-дуже сильно стріляти. Це було дуже страшно.
Там степ, навіть сховатися ніде.
Шкільний підвал став для дітей бункером, де вони ховалися під час обстрілів.
Вода, свічки та парти - цього достатньо, аби проводити навчання навіть за надзвичайного стану.
Дуже страшно… Не вірте тому, хто каже, що до цього можна звикнути.
До цього звикнути не можна.
Загинули троє діток в Гранітному. Двоє дошкільнят і один випускник 9 класу - Орест Балка.
Я навіть до цього часу пам'ятаю, де він сидів, його парту й почерк пам'ятаю.
Дуже талановитий, хороший хлопчина був.
Немає.
А психологічно постраждали всі.
Леся Степанівна показує нам, що залишилося від початкової школи через дорогу.
Снаряд повністю зруйнував будівлю.
На щастя, це сталося рано вранці, коли в приміщенні ще нікого не було.
Леся Степанівна мусить повертатися до класу.
З вікон школи можна бачити сепаратистські території, передова - всього за кілька сотень метрів.
У школі не залишилося жодної шибки, яку не довелося б міняти після обстрілів.
Перетинання передової під пильними оком українських та сепаратистських снайперів
стало тут повсякденням для багатьох дітей.
Цей міст - єдине, що ще сполучає Гранітне із сусідніми селами на боці сепаратистів.
Кінець шкільного дня. Діти рушають назад до контрольно-пропускного пункту.
Даша усвідомлює ризик такої дороги до школи, але вона хоче отримати атестат,
щоб поступити в інститут і стати вчителькою початкових класів.
Тоді вона повернеться у Гранітне, щоб учителювати у своїй школі.